- NOW GO--LOOK AT THAT.
- WHAT?
THAT'S AMAZING.
- HE'S SO GOOD AT THIS.
- AMAZING.
- I KNOW,
LOOK AT YOUR POINTS.
- OH! OH!
OH!
- NICE! NICE!
- YES. DUDE.
YOU HAVE ABSOLUTELY
MASTERED THIS GAME.
- YEAH, WELL, SINCE,
UM, SHEILA LEFT,
I'VE BEEN SPENDING
A LOT OF TIME PLAYING THE GAME.
- YOU'RE DOING REALLY GOOD.
- THANK YOU.
- THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE, MAN.
HELP YOU GET OVER SH--HER.
AND CHECK OUT THIS
AWESOME NEW GAME YOU HAVE!
- [weakly]
YAY.
- YOU KNOW, I LEFT SOMETHING
IN ANOTHER ROOM.
UM, EXCUSE ME, EVERYONE.
- OH, HE STILL
HAS THE SENSORS ON.
[chuckles]
- OH, LOOK.
- IS THAT HIM IN HIS ROOM?
- YEAH. YOU CAN SEE HIM.
THAT'S FUNNY. WHAT IS HE DOING?
IS HE--IS HE ON HIS KNEES?
DID HE DROP TO HIS KNEES?
- OH, N--[chuckles]
- OH...
- THAT--THAT--
HE'S PROBABLY LOOKING FOR--
- NO, LOOK.
HE'S--HE'S CRYING.
HE'S CRYING. OH, NO.
- HE'S JUST--
- NO, NO, HE'S SHUDDERING.
- THAT'S JUST SHAKING.
- HE'S SHUDDERING.
IS HE FETAL?
YEAH, HE CURLED UP.
LOOK AT THAT. HE'S FETAL.
- HEY, CRAIG, BUDDY.
YOU ALL RIGHT UP THERE?
- OH, YEAH, I'M--I'M--I'M--
I'M COMING RIGHT OUT.
- OH, HE--UM...
HEY, MAN, YOU ALL RIGHT?
- YES. YEAH. OH, YEAH.
YEAH, YEAH.
IT'S JUST,
UH, MY SINUSES...
[sniffs]
ARE ACTING UP.
YEAH.
YEAH, I, UM--
I WAS JUST--YOU KNOW, I WAS
JUST THINKING ABOUT SHEILA,
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M--I AM TOTALLY OVER HER.
- AWESOME.
- LET'S--HEY, LET'S GET
THIS PARTY STARTED.
- SURE.
OH.
UH...
I FORGOT TO GET RID OF THIS
PICTURE OF SHEILA. EXCUSE ME.
- HEY, MAYBE LEAVE THE SENSORS
SO ONE OF US CAN PLAY.
[game music begins]
- OH, HE'S DANCING.
HE'S DANCING WITH THE PHOTO.
IS HE KI--
HE'S DOING--
HE'S DOING THIS A BUNCH.
- ALL RIGHT.
- IS HE KISSING IT?
I THINK HE'S KISSING IT.
- KNOW WHAT?
I'M GONNA TURN THIS OFF.
'CAUSE WE DON'T NEED TO--
- YOU CHANGE IT AND YOU DIE.
HE'S UNDOING HIS BUCKLE.
LOOK AT THIS.
HIS PANTS ARE COMING OFF.
OH, GOD.
- YEAH.
- NO, NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
- OKAY, THAT'S HAPPENING.
- OH, NO, NO, NO.
- MY GOD.
- IS HE--HE'S--
HE IS TOTALLY ON THE BED.
- YEAH.
- HE'S TOTALLY FLAT
ON THE BED.
- OKAY, WELL, THAT'S JUST--
- OH! OH, GOD.
OH, GROSS.
[groans]
- WE SH--WE SHOULDN'T BE...
OKAY, YOU KNOW...
- IS HE REACHING DOWN
FOR HIS FOOT?
- I DON'T--
- THAT'S HIS FOOT, ISN'T IT?
IS THAT HIS FOOT?
- AND COMING BACK.
- WHEW.
I AM SORRY, EVERYBODY.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TO MAKE SOME SNACKS?
- WASH YOUR HANDS FIRST?